what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and oh my god someone traveled to 2001
and called jack bauer
because lady loki just bombed the sacred
timeline
how rude the timekeepers were working
hard on that for a long time
before time in a land before time known
as the tva i mean supposedly because
like mobius
i've never met the timekeepers
personally so for all i know
renzlaire could be doing all the work
while the timekeepers are on the top
floor
playing galaga batman is playing galaga
but why the hell are these time keepers
so elusive anyway how come they never
want to kick it out the water cooler i
mean casey looks like a nice guy
i mean what is the time keeper's big
secret that they care so much to keep as
classified as possible i mean this
pissed off lady loki variant
clearly has enough of a problem with
them to send a warehouse full of
freaking timeline bombs to destroy
everything that the tva stands for what
secret plans are the timekeepers keeping
from everybody
that has this feisty female frost giant
wanting to kick him in the [ __ ] well
let's go on and speculate speculation
nation because your boy once again
has a very weird but i think interesting
theory because i think the timekeepers
are secretly the time twisters
no i don't mean those little devices
mobius uses on loki to loop him into
submission
these tva time twister devices are
actually an easter egg for one of the
arch enemies of the time keepers
in the time variance authority as a
whole the time twisters
an easter egg that could be the seeds of
the reveal of the timekeeper's
big secret by series end now in the
comics the time twisters are actually
technically variants of the time keepers
themselves because long story short the
time twisters were created at the very
end of time
by the last ever director of the tva
known as he who remains
to effectively act as the stewards of
the timeline for the next universal
cycle
the crusty old man's goal was to make
these time keepers
give them these incredible powers to
manipulate temporal energy
and then shove the combined knowledge of
the entire last universal timeline into
their brains
so the next universe can learn from the
mistakes of the past universal timeline
however when he did this he unknowingly
split the next reality into two
realities
one where the good time keepers were
born and babysat the timeline
and one where the evil mentally warped
time twisters were born
and baby shat on the timeline it's all
really
super complicated but basically the main
goal of the time keepers and the time
twisters
are to make sure their team is on top in
the next universal timeline cycle like
the time twisters really want to make
sure that they get born at the end of
time
rather than their good guy timekeeper
counterparts it's like this weird
timeline war between these two groups of
entities
with the time twitters even going as far
as taking over the entire
tva by impersonating the timekeepers at
one point
now while i don't think the mcu was
going to adapt that keeper twister beef
exactly how it went down in the comics
and thank god because that [ __ ] was
really complicated i do believe that
this struggle for power between these
two groups
could have existed nonetheless in fact
there is a good chance that this
conflict could be that multiversal war
that miss minutes was talking about
in that animated presentation a war
between the time keepers and the time
twisters that somehow left the time
twisters on top to shape the timeline
however they saw fit i mean hell we
literally saw the secret timeline being
twisted together
by the time keepers in the animation in
episode 1. but hey before i continue
this video i just want to give a huge
shout out and thank you to helix sleep
for sponsoring this video helix sleeps
makes premium mattresses embedding that
are customized to fit your needs and
conveniently shipped
right to your door i mean everyone's
different and helix knows that and so
they made a sleep quiz that matches your
unique body type and sleep references to
find the perfect mattress
for you i took the quiz and i got
matched with the dusk
lux helix mattress because i wanted a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that keeps cool
i mean i've had my helix mattress for a
little bit now and i've got to say
i freaking love this thing i mean i
sometimes lose sleep thinking about the
next day's video or just
all my weird marvel theories but it's
never because of an uncomfortable
mattress and the number one
best part about all this is that helix
delivers your mattress
right to your door like for free and it
comes rolled up in a box and it's super
easy to set it up yourself
it's literally the coolest magic trick
in the world that they can fit such a
huge mattress
in such a tiny box that size now helix
has a 109th sleep trial so you get more
than three months to make sure that you
love it and if you don't
you'll get a full refund i love my helix
and i think you would too and if you're
looking for a new bed
check out helix you can click the link
below or go to helixleep.com rockstars
and get up to 200
off your helix mattress now i don't know
about you but if i just want a major war
for control of the time flow of the
multiverse i'm gonna make sure no one
ever tries to steal my [ __ ] because then
i'm gonna have to fight somebody and
frankly
war not fun well it is a good fall
absolutely nothing and that right there
could be the exact reason why the tva
exists
in the first place not to preserve the
sacred timeline like the timekeeper said
that they are doing
but to keep new realities with their own
timelines from sprouting up after a
nexus event passes redline because more
timelines could mean
more time keepers and or time twisters
and subsequently less power and
authority than they have now and maybe
that's when we kick off another time
keeper time twister
war if the war even happened in the
first place because those time twisters
impersonating the time keepers
could be lying now why do i believe that
the time twisters could be involved in
this season of loki well
let's take a look back at that time
theater scene from the first episode of
loki particularly
in the specific instance when moby's is
explaining to loki that the time keepers
have put the sacred timeline
on an eternal loop play the clip jon
you're lying
it's not true it is true that's the
proper flow of time and it happens again
and again and again because it's
supposed to
because it has to the tva makes sure of
it
and then immediately following this when
loki goes to attack him for calling him
a mama killer mobius uses the time
twister on loki and then says
or the time twister just loops you not
the furniture i believe that this moment
was written
100 intentionally to foreshadow the true
secret nature of these so-called
time keepers because much like mobius's
time-twister device that loops whichever
sucker
is currently you know wearing the collar
the time twisters taking on the name of
the time
keepers are looping the events of the
sacred timeline
keeping loki and everyone else in the
sacred timeline on the same
hamster wheel of fate but the question
remains
why because like if these time twisters
are disguised as time keepers
and are trying to prevent the sacred
timeline from branching out into a
massive multiverse
what do they get out of this new twisted
and regulated timeline
i think there is a good chance that it
probably has something to do
with quantum energy you know that
sparkly stuff janet van dyne sent scott
lang to go get to heal a quantumly
[ __ ] up ghost
at the end of ant-man in the wasp we
learn in ant-man and the wasp that
quantum energy is some pretty god level
stuff
i mean you have to remember that ghost
was time sick on a molecular level
her entire life and yet janet van dyne
was somehow able to stabilize her with
his quantum energy within seconds
seemingly with the power of prayer but
it was actually quantum energy they just
looked like they're
they were just having a moment never
mind it wasn't that funny
and since quantum energy is specifically
what the tva routinely monitors
to track variants and variations to the
timeline it makes sense
to me that this quantum energy could be
the very energy that the time twisters
could want to effectively
hoard into one timeline and every time
a new timeline starts to branch off from
a nexus event
some of that yummy yummy in my tummy
secret timeline quantum energy
leaks out and threatens to decrease the
overall power
of the time twisters and you know make
new realities with new timelines where
there were new time keepers and or time
twisters
could be made to fight with the other
times
it's the whole war scenario well it is a
good phone
so what do these time keepers do they
hoard this multiversal stash of godlike
quantum energy by putting everyone on
the timeline from avengers
to aliens to asgardians on a
never-ending
loop of fate because telling the story
of the universe from beginning to end
the exact same way every time ensures
that the time twisters will always be in
charge
and will always be eating good every
single time the universe recycles
because their timekeeper enemies would
never exist enough to stop them from
feasting on the combined quantum energy
of the marvel multiverse sentences like
this is why i can't get laid
because frankly it's easier to prune the
same tree that you've grown a thousand
times before because you know how the
branches are going to grow
this is extremely similar to me to the
concept of the luma fates introduced in
the story of ragnarok in the marvel
comic because to free asgard from the
endless cycle of ragnaroks that the gods
of the asgardians known as
those who sit above in shadow were using
the energies from to sustain themselves
thor destroys the norn loom of the fates
which then
seemingly destroyed those who sit above
in shadow with it
i think that this lady loki variant is
seeking to do a very similar thing on a
universal scale
in the mcu by ending this restrictive
looping of the sacred timeline
and let the natural chaos of the
multiverse just do its thing
and that our variant loki that we're
following might end up helping
lady loki with this exact goal not
because it's the right thing to do
but so every loki in every reality has a
chance
to be whoever they want to be because
i'm not sure if you notice this but uh
loki's really don't like being told what
to do
and this is exactly where i believe
loki's character development lies in
this series
loki will go from this would-be ruler of
midgard who believes that he has the
authority to decide all of humanity's
fate
to a loki who realizes the value in
choice and free will
after discovering just how shitty it
feels to not be in control of your own
destiny that is
one hell of a reverse uno card from the
tva if i ever did see one
but that's just my theory what do you
guys think do you guys think that the
time twisters
could actually be at play here or do you
think that the timekeepers have a
different secret
speak to me below my nerd babies but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video and be sure to
follow
me at mastertainment on twitter and
instagram if you want to see me post
some weird
random [ __ ] but most importantly please
follow new rockstars on youtube and make
sure to hit that notification bell so
you can get notifications
every time we upload new stuff but you
can also follow us on twitter because
you know
we be tweeting but yeah thanks for
watching guys catch you guys later
[Music]
you